شهر رمضان اهم مواسم رواج السوق الاواني
المنزليه في موريتانيا ينتظره التجار طيله
العام وفي كل رمضان تقتني السيدات
وحاجياتهن المختلف الاواني سواء تلك
المخصصه للمشروبات او للوجبات الرمضانيه
المختلفه
يبدا الاخبال مبكرا على شراء الاواني
ومستلزمات المطبخ قبل رمضان باسابيع
ويستمر خلال ايام الشهر المبارك ومع كل
رمضان يستورد تجار الاواني منتجات جديده
من الخارج بهدف عرض بضائع مختلفه عن بضاعه
العام السابق تحقيقا للاستفاده اكبر من
الموسم
الحمد لله
كل عام في الجوده وفي الناس اليوم
2500 ان شاء الله
يرجع الاقبال على شراء الاواني المنزليه
في رمضان الى العادات والتقاليد الغذائيه
خلال هذا الشهر حيث تتنوع المعده
الموريتانيه ويضاف لها عديد الوجبات
والمشروبات التي لا تحوى خلال بقيه العام
بما تحوى به من اقبال واهتمام خلال شهر
رمضان ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط